foreign
s Us in Knoxville Tennessee Rachel how
can we help
hi guys can you hear me I can loud and
clear what's up
all right so me and my husband were just
talking about possibly living in a
different state and the one that we both
kind of were interested in living in was
Alaska and where we went to Tennessee
that's a huge move yeah so we were just
wondering if that sounds crazy is there
any Financial guidelines that you have
for that anything against it for it any
any unbiased advice you could give us
well
George I want to jump in before we even
get to the money recommendations on
moving as I'm sure we both got some
opinions on that done that a lot
um
why do you think it's crazy
or are you wondering if anyone else
thinks it's crazy that was really the
first question absolutely both of our
families would think it was crazy all
right so they think it's crazy
but you and your husband don't think
it's crazy in fact now you probably have
a different adjective I want you to pick
the adjective just for fun you're not
locked into this what's the adjective
that you would use for moving to Alaska
if it's not crazy it is
fun exciting yes potential wow that's
great I think that's fantastic
so the reason your family doesn't like
it
is because they're sad
because you're scared
maybe they're confused
because you pursuing this fun exciting
Journey
is filtered to them as
you're leaving us
you are abandoning us you are robbing us
of time to see you and the kids and
everybody else do you see how it's
completely different
translation for them when they hear this
yes yeah all right but here's the deal
would you rather disappoint them by
moving to Alaska and having this awesome
fun Journey that you and your husband
feel that you guys are meant to do
uh or would you rather resent them by
not leaving
and always wondering what could have
been
what would you rather choose when you
put it like that that's eye-opening yeah
that that changes the narrative
completely there we go I'm glad our
opinions won't sway you then you you
want to do this I think people who run
marathons are crazy they love it and
they enjoy it and so it's a it's a great
analogy of what's right for you may not
be right for someone else so I'm all for
this move you asked about the financial
details there are a few steps you can
take to step into this without a bunch
of fear but instead excitement you've
done the homework so are you guys debt
free
we are dead free yes and we have um yeah
we we do have about ten thousand dollars
just in
Investments uh 14 000 in emergency funds
four thousand dollars in the bank for
business thinking funds so yeah that
gives me great peace about this move now
there are going to be moving expenses so
make sure that's set aside that's not an
emergency so let's set that aside as
well and begin researching you know what
what's the quality of life going to be
like what do we need to know about the
weather uh commutes schools
um you know areas of crime what's the
cost of living going to be have you
looked into all that
no that is that is exactly why I called
you we were we didn't didn't consider
that at all other than just where do we
want to live and where can we find a job
great and another resource for that of
course is people who actually have lived
in Alaska or currently live in Alaska so
that would also be something I can talk
with someone face to face versus just
reading a Blog about Alaska is going to
be more helpful especially in the city
that you plan on moving to so are you do
you have jobs lined up there or are you
working remote
that's where that's what we were looking
into is where we could find a job so
that that would be the first step
absolutely okay so let's start there
let's start with what we currently have
skill and experience in right so we want
to start the search there this is what
we are doing this is what we can do and
we begin to look and see because you
just I've been to Alaska I spent six
months there one time working on a a
campaign and it's a very spread out
remote so things are very concentrated
if you're in the Anchorage area you know
you're going to have a pretty good
representation of just most mid-sized
cities that's what that job economy
looks like in Anchorage it is very very
different in the outskirts of Alaska do
you understand what I'm saying are you
guys thinking Anchorage uh Suburbia of
Anchorage are you thinking like
outskirts these smaller towns where
we're flying a plane just to get
anywhere
where we don't know the area at all we
were thinking Anchorage and then
figuring out once we got there all right
um this is not related to job but this
is related to this whole decision you
guys need to probably go spend more time
there just on vacation like scouting
trips before we make this move I love
that yeah that you're that you're
thinking about this adventure and you're
taking this season of life you're debt
free so you can do it but I got to tell
you something this needs to be let's go
spend a week there let's go see three
cities uh let's let's look at the list
that I just told you to create and and
let's dive deep and and begin to maybe
apply and just go through some
interviews just to see we've got to get
our feet wet on this deal this is not a
jump in all the way I don't like that at
all because this dream this dream could
become a nightmare pretty quickly
so we're looking at what is it really
like there
and what is the job opportunity so we're
sustaining ourselves and able to fund
our adventure that's first and foremost
and then we begin to put the plan
together George I I yeah boy I don't
like just going wee that's it feels like
no no we wouldn't do that we wouldn't do
that that's why we called to ask what
should we be looking for I know but I
want to challenge you on that let's
let's get ourselves you know very
informed this is the stage that we call
uninformed optimism like when you start
something new you're just so excited
about it and you don't have enough
research to even be pessimistic about it
and the next stage is informed pessimism
where you start to feel a little
overwhelmed because you started doing
the research you're like oh this is a
lot and so there's going to be a journey
of ups and downs and a lot of emotion
around this and you may end up not
moving you may go visit and say it's a
fun place we love to visit there once or
twice a year we're going to stay planted
in Knoxville for now uh that might
happen are you guys homeowners right now
no no we're not okay you're renting so
consider do we have to break a lease is
there a fee involved with that should we
wait until the lease is up so there's
some logistical pieces when it comes to
housing you want to think about here too
what do you guys do for a living
electrician and dietitian
okay well I like the electrician play I
think that's going to probably be very
much uh excuse me there'd be a lot of of
opportunity there uh but you've got some
work to do on dietitian and what that
may or may not look like there but an
electrician in the trades in Alaska I
like this I like this a lot I told my
husband I was like he probably would be
able to find a job before me yeah yeah
all right well we've got a great
resource for you at ramseysolutions.com
how to move to another state it's got
all the stuff I've been mentioning I'll
make sure Austin gets you a link to that
you can also just uh search for that on
your favorite search engine but that
will start to give you a checklist of
the things you need to do the homework
ahead of you in research and make sure
you've got a job lined up before you
make this move the last thing you want
is for this to turn into a real
stressful situation George I want to get
them off to a head start let's check one
thing off the list I gotta talk to our
friends at PODS moving and storage yes
how do you even think about going from
Knoxville Tennessee to Alaska without
calling myself
huh one less thing to work they got the
storage they got the moving in other
words they take care of your headache
that was good Ken nice so smooth well
I'm excited about this Alaskan Adventure
hope it works out Rachel send us some
salmon
can you do that I just saw an ice maybe
on Ice I don't know how long it keeps